are you ready go I should look at you or
the camera mr. go so welcome to our
periodic table videos this is an
experiment for me just as much as it
will be for you when you're watching
your mind is a bit like soup it has to
be stirred up all the time and then
interesting vegetables float to the
surface the next element has simple I
knew nothing about her soon should we
make something up I expect it to be
quite so Wow the valer pop and I think
you got the pop oh it's on your camera
oh it is 225
this is what took quite a while what's
going on there
we have this periodic table it was
installed here 10 years after ladies
death no McDonald's cheeseburger we will
need more elements this isn't the first
cost I've had on gotta keep hold of it
Wow lovely we're into rim
it's nice sunny weather in Stockholm we
here at the Institute of heavier and
research the birthplace six elements I'm
here in Mumbai so here we are on the
summit of the Kolkata Bondi Beach in
Sydney
I'm sitting here possibly the same
ethnicity
more than enough
over 300 standard tablets of Viagra so
I've got my Wiggly giggly I'm here at
Mount Everest base camp those guys
behind me are boiling water for you and
periodic videos
just there
we're gonna need a bigger boat
we're in the vault the boolean bullet
with the Bank of England and I'm really
excited I've never seen so much gold in
fact I've never seen so much of any
element
you can imagine the periodic table bit
like a family photograph